je vous remercie d'être en direct avec
nous sur rt france un rapport alarmant
spurs à 11% des personnes interrogées
déclarent avoir été victimes de
discriminations liées à l'origine ou à
la couleur de leur peau en 2016 est ce
que ces chiffres vous semble réaliste ou
sous-estimé il me semble réaliste mais
surtout je vous tiens à l'autre chiffre
qui a été cité au début du mois dans un
article paru le 10 juin sur le figaro
par exemple qui est identique à un autre
chiffre du défenseur des droits déjà
publié en janvier 2017
il ya trois ans et demi chez free qui
indique que les personnes perçues comme
noirs ou maghrébins ou d'origine
maghrébine aurait 20 fois plus de chance
ou de risques d'être contrôlées par les
forces de l'ordre va fois ça c'est un
chiffre plus parlant encore donc c'est
évidemment corrélé au lieu d'habitation
ou plutôt parfois au lieu de relégation
auquel on assigne des personnes dans la
mesure où nous avons une ségrégation
sociale spatiale qui n'est pas tout à
fait celle des états unis dans les
villes nord-américaines nous avons une
assignation assez claire de lieux ou à
vitré une personne tout noir ou plutôt
blanche à français plus une ségrégation
sociale en raison de la situation
sociale familiale
toujours est il que celle ci prend soin
des couleurs des couleurs on va
d'ethniciser parce que les personnes
d'origine immigrée
par exemple quand deux mois quand elle
demande un logement social en
statistiquement nettement plus de
chances de se voir attribuer un logement
de telle ou telle zone
évidemment ça forge aussi la perception
quand les policiers surtout les jeunes
policiers qu'on va renvoyer dans ces
zones pour dire vous allez faire votre
début de carrière là où les autres ne
veulent pas trop aller et donc qu'il se
forge de même une idée ce qui serait le
profil typique entre guillemets de
quelqu'un pouvoir être amené à commettre
un certain nombre d'infractions et donc
ils reproduisent des schémas qui vend
autoproduit autres reprises autour de
produire à un schéma de contrôle de
population et de violence structurelle
le problème il est là il n'est pas dans
la volonté individuelle de tel ou tel
fonctionnaire ou dans le sadisme
individuel ça peut exister mais ça doit
être très rare
nos problèmes il est systémique dont la
corrélation entre lieu d'habitation des
uns et des autres perception de là où
c'est typique que quelqu'un devrait
inviter quelqu'un évidemment une
situation sociale et scolaire pour les
enfants et les jeunes qui grandissent et
qui va avec
le fait d'habiter dans des zones perçus
comme des zones de ce conte d'orge et
puis le comportement des phases de ruck
qui va avec forces de l'ordre dont les
membres sont parfois elle même victime
d'un système qui dit voilà toit sans
formation sans lien avec un territoire
on va te faire subir un travail dans un
lieu à imposer qui est présenté comme
dangereux qu'on présentait comme un lieu
à risque avant de pouvoir en sortir une
fois que tu auras accumulé suffisamment
de l'ajournement justement le défenseur
des droits jacques toubon propose de
revoir les textes qui encadrent à les
contrôles d'identité puisque vous parlez
de deux policiers on voit que il y à une
colère chez les policiers qui sont
d'ailleurs accusé de raciste aussi
dénoncent un petit peu ce terme et qu'il
juge de ne pas ne pas l'être est ce que
voilà revoir justement les textes pour
qui encadrent ces contrôles d'identité
sont suffisantes selon vous non il sera
ce suffisant
ça devrait aller de pair avec un effort
de formation important mais aussi
souvent surtout une territorialisation
c'est à dire sous d'autres formes un
parc en répétant à l'identique ce qui a
été fait mais ce qui a été tenté il ya
une vingtaine d'années avec la police
dite de proximité qui était en parfaite
qui posait d'autres problèmes donc sous
le monde sous la mandature 1997 à 2002
sous le gouvernement jospin pour ne pas
le nommer
avec une tentative au moins de créer des
îlotiers qu'ils aient un lien avec la
population locale surtout dans les
quartiers entre guillemets qui sont qui
sont vécus comme des lieux de relégation
entre guillemets et dans les quartiers
populaires donc il faudrait des comités
civiques qui puisse jeter un regard sur
le comportement des forces de l'ordre il
me semble qu'il faut alors pour la
police du quotidien qui en contact le
plus quotidien avec la police
désarmé la police qui rentrent en
premier en contact avec les populations
il faut certes des unités mobilisables
en cas de prise d'otage d'attentât et
c'est qu' elle soit pas désarmé mais la
police qui a au premier contact avec la
population elle devrait l'être à
désarmer il faut la démilitarisé il faut
la mettre en contact il faut créer
oui des groupes qui suivent qui met sous
un contrôle citoyen de ce que fait la
police
merci beaucoup bernard je suis d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes avocat au barreau de paris et
spécialiste du droit des étrangers